I [ __ ] do music for real for real I
[Music]
gave you ride a day and you gave me
games thank you thank you everything I
really think you got a shot like for
real I really do it's like it's funny
like as we've been doing the music thing
like the combination of Mike and I like
Mike and actually that's actually unfair
I think Mike really knows how to like
pick it but there's something funny
about the way I hear music that like I
just genuinely understand the masses I
just really think you have that kind of
sound I can like really go how can we
help you
first of all thank you for including me
in the playlist and thank you for
Twitter because that's been like help
already good anything that's organic
I feel like hits it's super Sam my fans
know like my audience is really cool cuz
they know I'm not like I don't know you
guys you're not doing anything for me
like like if I'm saying it like I mean
it you know what I mean like you know
like it makes me happy like it's super
fun like honestly it's no different than
like all the startups there's something
there's an amazing high I get from being
on like everybody likes it like
everybody loves discovering that band
and they I think most people get mad at
their favorite indie band when they go
mainstream like you know people yeah you
sold out like I'm the other way like
just like dreaming of a day like in six
years when you walk in here and
everyone's freaking out I think that's
cool
we're sitting in the way you see it I
don't know how much how much you see
that then Instagram and Twitter and
stuff like where do you think that we
could like increase our presence are we
lacking or like where do I think is
number one thing I think boy brought it
for like the number one thing I would do
of where you're at right now is do
collaboration songs with people outside
your demo like tomorrow I would do a
collab song with a country star tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow I would get a Latin
trap - uh-huh
tomorrow tomorrow I would I would get a
a Latin trap person to sing the hook of
a song here tomorrow now there's one big
little asterisk you've got to [ __ ] with
it like you got to believe in it got it
like if you're like this is wack I'm
just doing anything correct but if
you're like you know what I would do I
would [ __ ] make if I was them if I
was part of team I'd make you listen to
so much random [ __ ] because then you'd
be like yo this [ __ ] African [ __ ] is
rad as [ __ ] cool African [ __ ] come
back and be like yo you got to do this
with this person from [ __ ] Ghana yeah
you see where I'm going
I think people grossly underestimate the
collaboration to exciting people
understand how much Taylor Swift's song
with Kendrick Lamar matter to Kendrick
Lamar's career but I don't think people
really I think people think it would
have happened anyway and I don't and you
know what's crazy about hip-hop hip-hop
itself the whole [ __ ] genre took the
next step because of the Aerosmith Run
DMC collab the whole genre was not built
because it was authentically amazing but
it took there's nobody who's old like me
like especially people in the game ask
them it changed everything I think it's
what I would do especially this early in
your career if it's authentic I would do
songs with other people that give you
the upside of the awareness where it's a
trade of fanbase so I think you are
ridiculously talented so I think that
somebody who's like a huge pop star
who's fading or a midsize country star
who's stuck
they'll get the benefit of something
that's amazing talent you'll get the
benefit of like they have a much bigger
audience it's just a fair trade I'd make
a fair trade and I would probably not
put it in a project like I'd probably
just do it as one offs like I think a
great way to like build your music
career right now is you do mixtapes or
like projects that are just like
creative and like kind of strategic you
do albums for albums and then you do
one-off songs that are collaborations
that are strategic and fun and different
and our little curve balls to the
audience like you doing a song with
Backstreet Boys is exactly right today
I'm being serious you know what I mean
something that's like [ __ ] like so
off kilter to the mission I think
musicians have unbelievable permission
to do [ __ ] if it's the truth it's really
a hundred percent right one if you were
like oh my god I love Nelly Furtado
because when you were a kid that song
with Timbaland was so poppin and you
loved it so much she's not killing the
world right now but she's a real talent
like just DMing her and be like yo you
know what when I get it but I get like
that and you know what else and you know
what else there's people I replied to
today that of DME 46 times and today was
the day so trying comes in all shapes
and forms to
oh yeah oh it's true and that's what
we're the other thing I would say is
strike immediately if you see anybody
that you [ __ ] with like that like or
comment on social like strike hard like
there's always like a moment right like
let's say like it's whoever right bless
you
LLS bless you LL Cool J right like if he
likes a photo like you guys are like
like one of the things that I think I
always regret is not striking when it's
hot because I'm so busy right now like
I'm 18 months in to like Metro booming
and Kevin Hart [ __ ] with me on
Instagram but Kevin Hart like today and
I still haven't really like sat down and
break bread with the rock I [ __ ]
figured it out got it done but like and
like sometimes you just like six years
later and you still haven't connected
Kelly Rowland you know still oh I don't
reach out to anybody even though I give
that advice like now I meant like a
place where cuz I'm doing a little bit
different like if I was if I was doing
music I was and if I was like if I was
making content not documented content I
would but man I'm telling right now in
the second you see somebody a producer
or an artist that you [ __ ] with like or
engage on Twitter you just like get a
[ __ ] plane and being like in [ __ ]
you know like masterpiece studio and
[ __ ] in Louisiana got it cuz it's right
now it's the time to grind right now is
the time to be like not fancy about
nothing be like holy [ __ ] like we love
Big KRIT he just like this DM you hit up
you hit a Boyd or whoever the [ __ ] you
know your label I don't give a [ __ ] you
don't a full of crit and like yo we
should do something and this is what
everybody does yeah we should do
something yeah yeah and then nine months
later nothing happens when you're like
we should do something and he's like
yeah get the [ __ ] on a [ __ ] cheap red
eyed 88 bucks and we [ __ ] go
like if somebody cool and [ __ ] big
gives you love strike you know the
biggest thing that I've been playing
with like an econ crit like a lot of
good people have been sitting down like
I'm like look you're an artist I'm not
gonna tell you what the [ __ ] do I'm
even like scared to do it but I'd be
lying if I didn't say like if you've got
if you got
music in youth all of it should come out
differently [ __ ] songs we would have
from [ __ ] Michael Jackson and Biggie
and Prince and [ __ ] The Four Tops if
they had the technology we had today you
imagine yep you know I think that it I'm
gonna tell you something controversial I
don't think there's enough music
you got to give yourself every chance to
do it do you know many people could have
been the biggest artists in the world
that weren't because they didn't get the
right at-bats do you know many people do
you know many artists right now could be
John Legend but they took the one song
that was the song off the album that's
real life tell you that right now
so you you but there's a lot of ways to
do it like you know now you guys have so
much luxury it can be an album it giving
up the projects all these different
names for this [ __ ] it's all the same
[ __ ] like you could be a single one-off
you can do a whole thing like called
like but honestly I understand I really
believe that is what I believe like if
you and I like blue you're brother and
sister and we were like [ __ ] ghetto
Dalek didn't know anybody didn't have
all these good people around us
I'd be like listen to me sis like
[ __ ] let's just put out song every
day what and with our 87 followers on
Instagram all you need is you'll get it
I believe in that so I [ __ ] with rust I
think it's right I believe in it and
here's why
wherever Russ ends up is gonna be
predicated on this talent but first you
got to get the edge back the at-bat you
gotta get the chance people like don't
get it
and also how good are you like for us as
I keep listening he's gonna have to
evolve his sound right cuz a lot of it
sounds similar right I had to go through
this I don't think Russ is done
I think Russ is gonna have to Bob I did
I can sound similar right for three
months a year even 18 months and then
[ __ ] will change you're gonna win if
you're good enough cuz winners win in
the end but you can't not give yourself
the most chances to win
that's what I believe and so like if you
start a whole like maybe like it depends
how much music sitting in your soul and
sit how much you have I thought so
straight up I thought so so honestly I
think you need to do something called
like so for so cool Saturday and just
drop a [ __ ] 52 songs if you got it
like that I mean it keep aspire because
where you're at right now by the 13th
one it's building momentum and it just
might be the one that you drop on
September 6 and away you go
it's like there's nothing the record
like nothing will Trump the Internet
the way that this one song isn't working
one question that had because there's so
many artists that were around and if we
like okay they got four million
followers by their followers on social
media
they're not really your presence and I
heard his retort Carter from Spotify
where he said he's like record labels
and artists think that they broke but I
bet you if I put that same artists in a
high school the second kids would
strengthen face always gonna know the
forest and everything to go to inside it
so my question is how do we get an
artist like the stranger things kids by
putting out more songs more content more
stuff more more more more MORE
if PB rock walked in here right now most
people would have known
hi great man reality it's just the same
old thing man it's more I mean they're
one song away logic song could have been
the you know phone numbers song in the
album oh and it could have been a song
they put out one off
it just works that way like a little
baby's project right now is that an
album or is that a mix tape doesn't even
matter little baby
oh yeah you know it's just here's why
one girl in LA who like thinks you're
pretty and thinks you're cool retweets
it happens to be the [ __ ] niece of
[ __ ] Rihanna's hairdresser they're
sitting right like people don't get it
you can't understand how real that is
guys and then all of a sudden that
hairdresser plays it I mean I was like
what is that mom you know Rihanna is in
the mood she's in the mood to like put
somebody on for no reason other than she
can and she does what [ __ ] Kylie
Jenner did with PMB rock and lip syncs
one hook and your [ __ ] life's over
overnight figures times 4,000 plus you
never know what its gonna come from like
you've got the Megan and all the music
stuff and then you got a 42 year old
businessman who's got an audience that
[ __ ] [ __ ] within that [ __ ] like
it helps you to like the amount of
people that tell me like my cosign has
been bigger for them than like real
[ __ ] like [ __ ] you know like stuff
they were looking for
Yeah right like you know Oh an eSports
[ __ ] eat gamer on Twitch [ __ ] with
you and just starts playing in the
background happens to be ninja game over
I'm about to be we built a huge twitch
studio but you know what I mean you
never know right
doesn't matter two years from now
Instagram and twitch today a two years
from now [ __ ] knows right blockchain may
do this
hey I may do that voice may do this
here's what's up you have one song way
I got 140 you should there's a Netflix
documentary called
the toys we grew up with you've watched
it but you've seen it right you should
find out who produces it deep email them
and tell them to use figures in it
because it's all about action figures
and like like got it like got it just
caught it be like listen we have this
incredible artist we have incredible
song that went viral for her
it's called figures like we love action
figures like you want to use it in the
in like the background of like season 2
all of a sudden got people listening to
it and they're just like I oh wait you
know I just bring this up Good Charlotte
Good Charlotte broke because I'm Adam so
like how do you get your songs just
heard
[Music]
best [ __ ] cool house always the
studio closed there it is
we're closed yeah this twister yeah I'm
gonna touch - no you're not - its Jesus
crazy there's a I thought there was
somebody there that was clean that's no
Tyler Tyler's like my admin loved loves
FIFA like loves it but yeah if you start
playing twitch on FIFA like this is how
my works you're doing that it's gets
shared some [ __ ] soccer player who
plays in [ __ ] Europe who's got 8
million fans like who's this pretty girl
playing [ __ ] fever DMS you trying to
creep you're like cool come you're like
business you're like cool come and play
with me now it's [ __ ] now it's 18
million [ __ ] people like this is why
this is how my brain works this is how I
think differently than I cool you got
Europe from the [ __ ] label cool my
man the [ __ ] soccer player has got 22
million people on [ __ ] Instagram
comes through when he's in LA and during
the offseason of the European League
after the World Cup please [ __ ] FIFA
with her takes the photo and it's game
over you got all of Europe got it I was
[ __ ] p.m. the [ __ ] out of him and be
like yo I'm sure he does
a DM gonna be like yo let's [ __ ] play
fifa let's play twitch because people
freaked but that's my strategy
I'm bring like draymond Green he's done
with the MB files he's coming to the
office we're gonna play NBA jams I'm
gonna play people in like this court
that they do on until it's your old
school because I don't play the new
shoots like [ __ ] double dribble from
Nintendo
huh I played it today but it's a new
controller and I go [ __ ] you know play
Tony Hawk's [ __ ] skateboard with Tony
hockey now like it's so much coming for
you you just need to [ __ ] strike yeah
one song away I believe that I mean you
guys make like I have I'm always very
careful with my overly aggressive like
one song away because I have empathy
like some people like you know the way
they think of like like it's tough like
I feel like I'm an artist as a
businessman so I get like somebody who
carefully curates 15 songs in their head
it makes this perfect [ __ ] story I
just know that 99.9% of the time it
doesn't for the end user it does when
they tell them what it was about it's
like you hear an album yo that's a great
album then she goes on [ __ ] bt or
[ __ ] like you know a documentary or
like [ __ ] on the internet there's
like yo this so the whole part of this
album was like what I was going through
during this week and oh but like not
really like it was like you see where
I'm going it's like Monday morning
quarterbacking whereas like if you like
just put out like like the one song away
I just thought I will never waver from
this because I know I'm right it's what
the Internet's about in the same way
that you should have made music videos
in 1984 to 1987 and a lot of people
didn't because if they thought it was
giving away free music and I was taking
away from sales I think you should make
as many songs you got in your heart for
Spotify and Apple music in as many
different ways as possible the end it
warm using and again
like not play the game but like also
watch legends like Howard elaziz and
like build such to man but still not
right listen Adele did got $100,000 ago
would Adele would Adele do that in 2018
the end was finally got the one record
though can't ever sleep and everything
to get to that place so it's the one
song need to get 100% people trying to
get fancy before their fancy
[Music]
let's get our what it's a little bit of
initiative this comes with nerves
micromanagement yep
what's your gesture to break out of that
tomorrow if she trusts you based on that
question she's got to let you do one
thing that looks like micromanage and
then she's got to see it's not that
scary it's hard when it's you by the way
the pulse of you like it's a lot easier
to trust when you're not the product
it's you so it's harder I get it like I
don't [ __ ] like let my like it's hard
I do
like like I won't even edit this this
whole blog I want to look at it but but
you know when you're the product
it's harder than like anything else but
yeah I mean like you you know depending
on what you're actually talking about
like scale only comes when you let go
and when you realize the audience is the
judge not you as long as you don't feel
horrible about it as long as they're not
telling you like yo you need to put on a
clown suit and go perform at this Bar
Mitzvah and sing Barbra Streisand make
music for people you know why let me
give you a real curveball
there you're gonna think it's cool when
you're old like when you're like your
grandkids are gonna think it's cool like
think about this you know we don't know
what's gonna happen but do it when you
can do it it's like imagine I'm gonna
make it real simple let's play it the
other way not about you about somebody
else imagine the people that could have
done collabs with Madonna and did it
right you know the you're the guy you
know what [ __ ] Harris ones thinking
right now that he said note that like he
instead of going to studio and doing
that song with biggie when Big E was on
the way up he decided to just stay at
home it's very true don't be fancy
before the fancy that's exactly right
got it
that's what's up like that's why I keep
meeting like people always like why are
you meeting with like all these people
like you should be meeting with other
people you know that much time I'm like
don't be fancy until you're fancy you
know like I go from like the meeting
range I go from I I want it like I have
come to realize in the last three or
four years like everything I thought was
true is probably true
which is like I'm I'm playing a
fundamentally different game than almost
everybody and like my goals break down
in things one I want to have no regrets
when I'm old
big right so like I'm squeezing
everything right number two I want to
have the most people ever show up to a
funeral of all time
there's a very important thing about
funerals it takes a lot for somebody to
not do their normal day or what they're
supposed to be up to and stop and travel
to somebody's funeral I'm trying to
figure out like I want my grandkids to
just cry and be like and by then I tend
like I honestly think I'm gonna be
famous like real famous
like honestly and I still think I do I
think I'll be real real famous right
I still think I'll have more people at
my funeral than anybody thinks because
there's a reason I'm becoming famous and
it's not because I can sing or because I
pretty or because I am good at
basketball the only reason people [ __ ]
with me is because I'm bringing them
value mentally you know like it's a
totally different wreath like you have
to understand the reason musicians are
so big like the escapism that music does
for people is all-time it doesn't for me
the reason I got real hype this weekend
was cuz I just listened to [ __ ] teat
Risley I remember like over and over
like 400,000 like I listened to it for
11 hours in the last four days 11 hours
hey cuz that's how I get because T
grizzly is gonna win because of the
opening line of that song which is like
you know I still think of 50 50 dollars
a lot of money
[Music]
all three of you will regret if you
don't squeeze the [ __ ] out of this for
the rest of your life if you don't pop
that's super real which is why I like
every clap every song like he'll just
regret it I don't notice to tell you you
will I know you're too far you're too
far along
it's too special it's too obvious you
know there's nobody sitting here that
doesn't know she's a star
I just know millions of stars never made
it I believe that I [ __ ] believe that
when you were because every teenager
goes through it when they're kind of
like this so uh so that was different
like like so here's what happened with
me as a teenager that's played out here
I answered a question better there are
very few teenagers that ever live their
life the way I did which is I couldn't
hear anybody man I couldn't can't tell
you just I can't tell you this like I
didn't hear anybody meaning think about
high school and like a kid like
everybody's opinions matters too much
I just valued nobody's opinion but mine
I was in my own head and not like we are
like I'm super social and like not the
awkward like like super outwardly like
normal like I'm unbelievably socially
like everybody liked me I just couldn't
hear you I think that I think both I
think my mom brainwashed me that I was
the best and thus I was like yo I don't
care like like yeah I was like I'm not
gonna like like when people like you got
a drink this to be cool like I don't
value those people enough but I love you
like I and I see that you're cool and
you're pretty and you're cool and you're
the most popular but like [ __ ] you like
I'm not [ __ ] drinking beer if I don't
wanna drink beer like my four best
friends in college like these are my
homies their only goal life was to get
me to take one hit from one blunt one
time in four years and I didn't do it
yeah
that was like the and let me think about
the silliness of that yeah like you know
what I mean like I just don't want to
that was it like lines of this so to
answer you I what happened it happened
god I don't even know when it happened
or how it happened but for some reason I
just never let peer pressure come in in
any shape form I was doing such crazy
[ __ ] I was like in high school like
going to like the dollar store buying
[ __ ] and selling it and like I do
baseball cards shows in the mall and
like all my friends are like when you're
a sophomore in high school you're like
trying to do it like you know like and
I'm like sitting in the mall like trying
to sell baseball cards and like I know
my friends and they're like even like
girls that kind of like me in high
school like like why are you like don't
do that thank you and I was like [ __ ]
you like I'm doing me and I've always
been that way and I think now it's
playing out where what's really manifest
is like that's the game the game is like
to do everything for you for them you
got a like I always think about being
selfish to be selfless I think I'm so
selfish in my own [ __ ] that then it
allows me to like that's why I can give
so much because I'm not looking for any
I'm not looking for anybody to give me
validation I'm not very validated that
means I've already moved on to the next
part I feel like I'm old does that make
sense I feel like I'm 90 like you know
like 90 rows like don't give a [ __ ] no
more like that's you know like they're
like I'm old like what are you gonna say
like [ __ ] you
what's that had to summarize it wasn't a
single piece of advice it was a process
that my dad put me through when I was 14
or 16 that said whether it is fine my
dad taught me word is bond and I'm gonna
give back money gaveta I was trying to
do music and do sessions and the
interviews and one of the mentors and
Ricky he was like honestly doesn't have
to resume through what you said earlier
we really got to be selfish to be so
deep become huge and music you do
everything your hundred honestly that's
exactly right like I want to capture
everybody's attention on earth so that I
can make an impact like like I know I'm
right
I want legacy honestly just just to
answer you I want legacy I want nothing
else man like honestly I don't want any
more money other than if I make enough
money to buy the Jets it's gonna inspire
everybody because I'm gonna have 30
years of content saying I'm gonna do it
and then I do anything to be like Olli
she's like it to be so like crazy other
than that and knowing like then I'll get
a movie about me and like you know like
you know the boy that bought the jet you
know you know like but like you know
other than that it was funny I was in my
house out east and I was looking at the
the sweater that my mom needed me cuz I
couldn't even afford Jeff's Jersey that
was a just I was looking at was like I'm
[ __ ] just had it like a moment of
myself I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] do
this I'm gonna [ __ ] do it
but that's more about the chase you know
that's kind of like if I was an artist
that's more like I'm gonna win 11
Grammys that's what we're about just
like doing like that see more but get
yeah it's a game but for real for real
the funeral you know the funeral like
that means you won like you know many
people make 48 million dollars and eight
people if their [ __ ] funeral like I
want people like I want people don't
know don't even know why they're at my
funeral
they're like I want people like mingling
with each other and be like why are you
here I'm like my grandma made me come
because in 2018 she watched a video and
she left my grandpa who was abusing her
and she built a business you don't
real [ __ ] real [ __ ] and I guess what I
get in DMS all day like Marie oh my DM
is a real [ __ ] right heavy [ __ ] yeah but
like mute the reason I think I'm
gravitating towards music is I recognize
for me to pull off all my ambitions I
need the biggest pillars in our culture
in our lives and music is one of those
sports I actually think that fashion is
one but that doesn't come natural to me
these are cultural players you know
thinners like things like religion
things that nature but that's almost
like a different thing but like music
and sports I want to die a legend or
wannabe able to fight that alarm I wanna
have a
myself I want to get to orphanage in the
name of after my mother and I'm gonna
help with my people it is years ago you
can really you can really do that but
your one song away from that everything
you just said your one song away from
being dip [ __ ] series of you let me
go no no stick with me stick with me
everything you just said like you can
add things later but like everything you
just rattled off the [ __ ] farm the
Grammys the million people you're one
song away logics [ __ ] song reached
more than a million people if you don't
think that [ __ ] hotline song impacted
a million people easy million millions
one song way that's what's up like
honestly I wish probably in a lot of
ways subconsciously unconsciously that I
could sing or rap because like the way I
communicate I can make viral videos but
[ __ ] I'd have seven did you see what
a t grizzly and Tara said about when I
was like oh you're not in the text you
see what they said I'm like texting and
I'm like lyrics this is just like random
ship and I would make videos about yeah
and it was funny and I was sitting there
I was like that makes so much sense that
they think that cuz like it's all the
same [ __ ] just spinning his own lyrics
he did sound like I couldn't make that
connection I listened the drink I didn't
make that connection but like I know
that it's all the same [ __ ] back to the
fine line your one song away from
everything you just said like I I think
I put some in sir in that poster yet the
I'm gonna I didn't we didn't make that
post yet I tweeted it but we don't the
ominous shove positivity down your
throat we nobody made it yet can you
know I'm like I'm like literally twitted
yes sir I'm like I'm gonna shove
positivity down your collective throats
like for the rest of time for my life
period and a story because it's the
truth
like how blessed we are [ __ ] are we
doing here
real [ __ ] how much your [ __ ] denim
jacket costs like you know it's like
more than my like family made in like
two months like I might [ __ ] dinner
bills so I didn't with my parents the
other night right I didn't with my
parents like a month ago which is rare
just the four of us right
the dinner bill was more than our rent
for the first two years we lived in
America [ __ ] are we doing here like
nobody in America should complain about
nothing no my dad we had a family liquor
business that's where I started and he
still goes in the liquor store today
causing ruckus and my mom was always
stay at home she's just being a grandma
and just like [ __ ] she [ __ ] worked
her face off man
like no help three kids like [ __ ] we
didn't do [ __ ] she did laundry clean
like old school like [ __ ] she was a maid
what's that
Belarusian oh you know lack of
entitlement
and what gets [ __ ] up is you can get
caught like all these crazy things
happening for you lose sight you know
I'm running it not me but everyone's
different right like everyone learns
different everybody you know I
definitely you know it's funny back to
this t grizzly song I'm not kidding
it was interesting how much it motivate
I was like okay wait a minute this is
good like it's cool to see an outside
source bring me some value like I'm in
my own [ __ ] I just can't not know my
perspectives to off the [ __ ] shark
like my perspectives a 30 on the 10
scale every second in my life I think
got it it's the same answer to the last
question I don't need a tactical thing
to ground me I'm grounded no you know
what I mean
it is you know what I mean like the same
way that I breathe oxygen I [ __ ] know
it's great and I'm thankful and grateful
as [ __ ]
and I know I'm the best and I know I
mean [ __ ]
[Music]
neatly I gave you ride a day and gave me
gay